a town hall peppered in bullet holes
this is the scene following a violent
attack against public officials in the
small town of San Miguel Toto lapan
at least 20 people have been confirmed
dead after gunmen stormed the local
government offices among those killed
during the attack was the mayor of the
Town conrado Mendoza Almera in a tweet
the governor of the Mexican state of
Guerrero called for a special
investigation and promised to bring
those responsible to Justice
Mexico's president Andres Manuel Lopez
obrador spoke about the attack during
his morning press conference on Thursday
in the case of totaloupan these
organizations that have been around for
a long time they did not emerge during
this government and we're trying to
address the causes
while the state of Guerrero has some of
the highest incidences of violent
homicide in Mexico authorities say
Wednesday's attack was particularly
shocking the latest violence highlights
how there are regions of the country
where Mexican security forces are
outgunned by criminal groups Manuel
rapalo Al Jazeera